for me some some of them are good and
juicy sorry years ago when you took your
let's say like if you went and you said
oh this is my partner um
what are your intentions towards my
daughter yes can I see your bank account
which is your job what are you and all
of that yeah and I remember going to
like weddings where I always thought it
was Indian people that had Diaries and I
remember having African friendly had all
this suitcase for the new clothes and
presents hair and jewelry there and I'm
like what are you doing I have to show
the family that I can support her yes
and it's like a whole ceremony of like
showing them what you can give a show in
the family and that's what I mean
nowadays it's too easy for people to go
and get married they have to show the
family that they can look after that the
problem is the women nowadays aren't
worth it like why would I do all that
when she's out here in the street
why would a guy do that for a 31 year
old wife because I've experienced this
recently and you know obviously I don't
have these traditional views right so
you know some of these guys are out here
counting body counts for me it's more
like in the way they act like I I I
messed around with like an older woman
like a few months ago 42 only ever been
with one guy you know like and I can
just when I'm around her it's just like
she's from a different age there was no
no she's you know she's gorgeous so I'm
not running but she's from a different
age like just the way she behaves The
Way She carries herself the way she
talks very soft very pleasant not too
opinionated it's just like it's just
like that she's like a real woman
I realized that being with her I was
like yo there's no one in my generation
that can like being around someone like
that I was like you know what I'm a
bachelor I'm probably gonna be a
bachelor for the next five six seconds
but hanging out with her I was like I
actually get why people like get married
on her own why is she 42 in single fussy
it's not your business I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna be saying that okay I always
say that's their story
like there's modern modern you know
problems have modern solutions but
there's a lot of stuff going on here in
London but still I'm not gonna lie um
do you want children uh ideally yeah oh
what shame what's stopping you are you
saying ideally
that's a bunch of things not meeting the
right person the reason I was asking
because that woman sound like she's
captured a bit of him but she's old you
know what I mean it's like actually no
children no one can capture me but I
think I think I was close I always tell
her like if you were like 25 20 years
younger that's why I asked about
yourself
because you sounded like if she could
breed and be healthy or whatever I'm not
I'm not missing out
yeah I was just like yeah yeah if you
were like 20 years younger yeah
I'll be getting some Factory job I'll be
like
did you have something you want to just
add
I forgot okay now you say you're not
gonna lie oh yeah yeah I ain't going
like um don't lie I'm scared to get
married why because um The Generation
Now compared to back in the days I'm
talking before we were born it was
different like back in the days when
when they meet each other they get
married into this stay together you know
what I'm saying about a generation now
it's like it's bad it's toxic what I
mean by that is that everybody's just
breeding each other everybody's having
babies in Egypt and then they're never
with that that same person if you get
what I'm trying to say and it's scary
man I've seen it so many times with a
lot of people and it affects me the
reason why I say it affects me because
it's not free on the child I don't know
excuse me imagine that you want to get
married now that's what I'm saying I've
always said like like say full song for
me I have a son
I tried so hard obviously to make the
relation work yeah I'm not saying I'm
perfect you know what I'm saying but I
was never acquitted I see as like if
you've made her family just but like you
gotta stick together for life you know I
mean but our generation I think I blame
the social media I feel like it's that
it's a distraction this is my honest
opinion technology yeah but it's a tech
launcher that's why I'm scared to get me
I'm scared like if I get married after
three years hold up wait a minute oh
she's gonna wanna take my money or she
wanna take my house can I ask you a
question when was the last time you had
sex
are you asking me yeah he's Jamaican
Nancy maybe like that I've got Jamaica
about fruit two days three days ago oh
are you serious about that person
no no because I'm asking that because
the way he's describing I'm tired of
people saying oh this is what I want and
his things have changed and they're
contributing to all we have to be that
what we want we have to be
accountability you can't turn around and
say this is what I want but what are you
doing to make that happen to make that
happen because the change don't come
from out there the change comes from you
within and if you want to see a change
then it's down to each individual to
start making the change you can't turn
around and say this is what I want I
don't want to be paddling in a muddy
pool when you're helping make the pool
muddy
because at the end of the day what have
you got to choose from
that you've really crept in
that's why I say self-love I hear that
answer but then but you get to ever have
to agree with the same thing even even
though you still love that person it's
just you know what you need to be you
know you need to be you need to be more
fussy more selective and
treasure your dick self-love I'm not
gonna lie to myself
as far as I'm concerned if you want
somebody good don't be dipping your dick
in somebody bad auntie I hear what
you're saying but for us men yeah and
I'm talking for awesome it's hard
enough you know safe sex jerk off then
you're not messing with nobody's mind
you're not messing with nobody's body
there's no chance that any contraception
is gonna fail and that you can preserve
yourself
you need to be more fussy that's the
right idea but I think I think from a
man to man right I think you focus that
energy imagine you're saving that energy
for like the one in it so but
masturbation porn I think is not the way
because
leads to leads to um oh man you're
leaving me hanging I was giving you a
spot right now come on down use the
other things and then it leads to that
lack of discipline but I would say Focus
that imagine you're saving that energy
for the one in it and it makes you all
the more intense because when you meet
that one you pull out all the steps
I'm just going to give you little
doubles advocate here okay I don't think
your generation really understands this
okay for for men like women like guys
that sleep around and and treat like
women modern women don't like men that
treat them like queens and the problem
is like if if guys
aren't sleeping around they start to
like think too highly of each girl and
treat them too well and modern women
don't like that it's not like in your
generation where like a girl's courted
and like they respect it and they're
excited like you can just Court the nice
girl and she she wants you like for them
it's like basically if they give a girl
everything She Wants then she doesn't
like them and girls don't like guys that
don't sleep around like they only want
guys that sleep around
if that's the case and you've already
got a child
don't have no more and get old woman I
hate our energy but then you get there's
some woman out there just just no I said
get an older woman an old mature woman
like the woman that he said that he
found one that's feminine she can't
breathe you've already got a son you
don't want no more children concentrate
on your one child have a happy
relationship with woman that can't
breathe
problems
[Laughter]
so you're gonna say you're gonna say
something
so my my what I think is it's modern
times cool for modern solutions in it
like that that free market of people
sleeping around with each other I think
that's always existed I think it's
always going to exist
um I think the fact that women value men
who are more experienced I think is a
sign of that just the selection in this
daily game has gotten a lot tougher I
think that back in the day guys guys
would get with women just because
they're in the right place and we're
born in the same Village she could be a
Victoria Secret model you could look
like you know Shrek and it's just like
well we were the same age I had a good
job it worked our parents liked each
other now you really have to work you
really have to be the guy in it and so I
I would I would definitely kind of
that's what I want to add that like it's
not all bad in it and it's just another
stat to kind of give you some
perspective women modern women find 80
percent of men as unattractive and so on
dating apps which people will argue that
maybe people on dating apps aren't
looking for something serious but that's
the number one way people people meet
women only swipe right five percent of
the time up to twenty percent on the
high end in certain studies so women are
all sleeping with the same guys so for
guys that are in that percentage it's
like they just have an abundance of
girls throwing themselves at them and
then the women will come back later and
say men are trash that's who who we need
to have a speed dating thing me and you
go yeah I have I need to set up a speed
dating or even a quoting thing when we
show them how to do it properly and give
them questions to ask you know speed
dating but we provide the questions look
at look at you you're we're helping me
open wife school right yes they turn
modern women into wives you need to try
we need to do it what we need to do we
don't want to be saved no they do I
think some do you know what right one
more thing
they want to have their fun and you know
what stop it Alex don't say that like oh
oh you know what the majority of women
what you're saying is right I'm not
saying that is wrong but why does it
always boil down to
no because you see what Nathan said I
like you Nathan by the way I appreciate
girls but what made me feel like you're
not scared you're more like scared to be
stuck in one because there's so many
options out there because you keep
dipping your cookie into the jars
different jars of different sauces so
but here's here so I think sorry the
reason why you don't want to come in I
feel like the way you explained to me to
one jar is because you're my ah because
you saw the other jar you saw the other
day you're like it might taste you said
too many options that's what you said
earlier
let me explain it to you so women leave
women divorced men 70 to 80 percent of
the time I I would argue in
relationships it's probably similar men
aren't leaving women are so to a guy's
point of view he's going to commit to
this girl and what does he get he
doesn't get Purity anymore you know
these These Hoes you know he doesn't he
doesn't get youth anymore so he doesn't
get either of those things a lot of
times she already has a kid so so he's
not fulfilling his mating strategy on
top of that even if he does find a good
woman that maybe has the qualities he's
looking for she was going to want him to
marry her right and what does he get out
of that oh she can leave and take half
and take my kids and she's paid to take
my kids away from me she she gets more
money if she takes my children and so
from the men's point of view they're
just kind of like eff it because like
women aren't wives nowadays
and what do they get out of it like men
are logical they're logical people and
so they're thinking does the benefit
outweigh the cost and like I just think
as women we have to look at ourselves
and say the benefits we bring nowadays
don't outweigh the cost for most men
you know as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible